ware dc dc youtube Hendler's nba shon hospital
If there is someone who continues to create it, I think it will be soon.It
's not that the pencil will get old, but computers are actually the same tools
as pencils.As long as the person who uses the tool continues to use it, each tool has
six powers.  I think there's a way to survive from there
to doing Mercury Animation It
's already Mr. Still in front of me
+ Sumikin from Bah I guess
there's a chain called
I
guess
.
It's a mistake, and I
knew that someone was doing troublesome things on the computer. It would
be fine if the animators wrote it themselves.
The
biggest problem is
that the computer is accurate.  Because we have such a personality, we also have to
write accurately, don't we?
They said that it would be better to write it as it is, with the feeling that we saw it with our own eyes.
It's still cheaper to buy a new computer than to buy a new computer
.
Computers are used in a variety of ways to complement the screens
. The
CG section has been eliminated, but rather than opening a c-office work course,
applicants can enter the office there.